[Applause]
so you had your fans make their own
videos for the new songs that's what
it's cool about an awesome song I feel
like it can float to different genres
and you like doing that but your next
album is about stepping into Joy so what
do you mean about that well I think my
first couple of records were about
heartbreaks and I was a dramatic
20-year-old going through heartbreaks
and stuff like that and um I when I sat
down to make this album the scariest
thing to do was to try and write
something that was when I say joyful I
mean it can't be joyful all the time
time but like it stepping into a
confidence and I cuz heartbreak was a
safe space for me so I've been like
playing with different emotions anger
sexiness uh joyfulness and it's it's
it's really exciting and I feel like I'm
in a dangerous place again and as an
artist I like to feel a bit scared yeah
before I release music because then I'm
doing something right I think
ooh I'm going listen to my album again I
so wait did that change your songw
writing process cuz I feel like it's
very easy for me if Heartbreakers
involved or struggle or some kind of
negative emotion it's easier for me to
write because it's fresh and it's just
like all right there and I need to get
it out but it it's harder for me to
write I think or it has been in the past
to write positively like you know so is
that is which one's easier for you I
mean you know what I can I tried to
write happy songs when I wasn't happy
and it didn't work and I think that I've
only been able to write some of these
emotions down because I'm you know I'm
not going through a heartbreak I hav
yeah I'm feeling good I'm feeling I like
my body I like my life I'm I'm turning
30 and 30 is fabulous and aging is
fabulous it is aging is the best yeah um
I've always been around amazing uh
people who love getting older so I've
always been excited to get older so I'm
enjoying it I always say that we're
lucky that we get the chance to be older
like a lot of people don't make it you
know we all unfortunately have friends
that have or family that haven't made it
and it's like I'm not going to down
these ring Les like I'm proud that I got
to live this long to have them you know
like not everybody
[Music]
[Applause]
does thank you guys y'all have a great
night I'm going
home